Tom Verducci here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Tom I'm good and thank you
for that public service of that warning
rich because you can also add once it's
in your head I ain't getting out for a
while so whose whose job is it gonna be
to explains that you were Rosenthal
tonight to explain it to the audience
when it happens if it happens today
who's gonna hear Joe bucko deep for 1 1
on on the shark and the whole story by
that you did a very nice job with that
by the way ok it's crazy I mean I don't
know that I've seen anything like that
in a ballpark where like when he's been
[ __ ] and his I think sometimes he
intentionally takes his time gay but
it's mean the only thing I could I guess
equated to is maybe the rally monkey
right that the Angels had in the early
offs with their Thunder station yeah and
the rally monkey no you had that the
Cardinals had the rally squirrel that
one year there's been all kinds of goofy
things that teams ride but this is as
sticky as they come but I'll say this in
all seriousness rich Park and kind of
the vibe he brings to the team as part
of the reason why I think this team has
been so hot for the last month I mean
you see during the games how much fun
they have in the dugout right I know
these need to have fun right but they're
like that all the time this had been a
tighter team no better example meeting
Stephen Strasburg you know he used to
walk around like you know his dog just
died every day of the week and he's
hugging it out in the dugout and these
guys are bouncing around and dancing
yeah he called it man this is as hot of
a team as you can find in the month of
October and man I having fun and the
thing that's even more remarkable about
it is Tom I was in the stadium we did
the you know our show from the all-star
game there last year and it felt like a
farewell to Brice during that homerun
Derby and everybody sense that everybody
knew it and everybody read into it that
that's the death of the the franchise
for years to come and instead now
they're in the World Series it's
unbelievable I mean that that as the
backdrop to all of this has been
remarkable how did how did it
but yeah don't forget they started
nineteen and thirty-one two and Devi
Martina this job was being called into
question yeah I think it happened rich
at this time of year at least because
this the first time at all these post
seasons that the Nationals have been
playing from the underdog role they
didn't have a lot of expectations in the
past they pitching Harper as you
mentioned winning division titles you
know taking game fives at home and they
would lose those games but this is the
first time where it was like alright
they're a good team but you know let's
see what they do against the Braves the
Dodgers the class of the National League
and now the 107 win Astros team they've
been in a really really good spot now
for a while I mean this is now I think
it's 32 days they've lost two games it's
like they've forgotten how to lose and
you know not even that break that six
days off between the NLCS in the World
Series to stop this team at all I'll
tell you right now this game obviously
it's a must-win game for the Astros
right you can't go down three nothing
that Greinke has to really go out and
just deal tonight because because the
Nationals have so much confidence the
only way to knock them back a bit is to
have your pitch or just throw a gem and
put some doubt in their minds because
right now they're starting this game
expecting to win the National well
there's no I shouldn't say there's no
way but when the Astros acquired Greinke
at the deadline they didn't have this
type of start in there in mind for him
right that this is this is this is no
they went to this world series of Cole
and Verlander at home you know they've
never lost back-to-back days that all
year and they lose both on at home where
they've just been incredibly good at
home so now Greg you're right in the
situation of not just being a guy to
fill out the rotation he has to be a
stopper and this is a guy who started
five postseason games in his career on
the road and he's never won any of them
I mean he's only one of about four or
five pitchers has never won a postseason
start on the road with five chances or
more hasn't pitched well this postseason
going you with extra rest and he's not
been good on extra rest he's in a tough
spot here the ton of pressure on Zack
cranky tonight but as I said it's on his
shoulders because someone's gonna have
to cool down that lineup Tom Verducci
here
the Rich Eisen show he's part of the Fox
broadcast tonight also MLB Network
analyst Sports Illustrated lead Major
League Baseball reporter a man of many
hats joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show how much of what's going on with
the front office of the Houston Astros
in the debacle that was created by the
front office in their reaction over the
last several days and then the press
conference yesterday with Jeff Luna who
just kept digging even deeper it felt to
me based on the way I was watching it is
that possibly affecting anything that's
going out on the field do you think Tom
I don't know that it's affected anything
on the field rich but it has affected
the vibe around the team in other words
once the game starts I'm not sure it
does matter but having to answer
questions as the manager has to do which
was really it was he was put in a
terrible situation AJ Hinch at that
first press release the team put out of
trying to pick up some pieces but it's
just create a bad vibe around the team
where these questions and issues and you
know are still out there because of the
way they flat-out mishandled this you
know calling report misleading and
fabricated from the start when they
really didn't have all the information
it was just these are really bad I mean
they it wound up doing the right thing
but I do think once you win the and you
win the American League pennant a
walk-off home run by a Jose Altuve who's
like you know rainbows and sunshine I
mean you can't find a guy who can put a
better smile on your face every day than
help do they and that that became the
narrative for the next 48 hours
so yeah the vibe around the team is bad
I wouldn't go as I want I don't want to
take anything away from the nets because
they've been that good right but it
certainly didn't help the environment
around the team preparing for the World
Series well I mean in for for you know
your colleague its Sports Illustrated
and Stephanie apps teen to be accused of
fabricating something and making stuff
up and it was just so virulent the first
statement that Lou now has now said he
was aware of but he wouldn't say who
wrote it and who genuinely generally
approved of it going out and then for
him to be asked about whether he had
apologized to her yet he said he was
busy flying hadn't had the
time she was in the room when he said
right there when he said yeah what
wasn't all begins with Taubman right
he's the one who has to take
responsibility his actions created this
mess but the fact that they totally
mishandled it from the get-go is
something that's systemic in the
organization and Jeff does have to
answer for that as well because
certainly multiple sets of eyes looked
at that statement before it went out and
that was your first reaction to
something to go attack the people
actually witnessed it
so yeah it's not just on Talmud it
became institutional in terms of the way
the Astros handled that and you know
Jeff clearly was one percent
uncomfortable with that even yesterday
you know pick up the phone you have to
call it Stephanie make it your priority
to take five minutes out of your day you
know to express a personal apology and
it still hasn't happened well I mean and
then you know the players obviously
still there and he's not the only one
with a history of this stuff do you do
you think that this might change the way
that teams actually employ players with
this history like Osuna and obviously
the Yankees with with their closer and
Chapman having a history of this do you
think this might change anything Tom I'd
like to say yes it still comes down to
talent you know the better players are
going to get more leeway on issues like
this if he is a fringe player a minor
league player and the Astros have
actually done this with a minor league
player where there was a domestic
violence incident actually was on on
video and they just released the player
but if you're talking about a guy now as
the closer on a team trying to win the
World Series
right unfortunately I think the answer
is no it's not going to change Tom
Verducci here on the Rich Eisen show and
speaking of the Yankees Brian Cashman
had his exit interview with the New York
media yesterday said that pitching
wasn't the issue as to why they're not
in the World Series it was timely
hitting and part of the reason why he
said that is Cole and Verlander were I
guess gettable at some point for the
Yankees and it was posited by a member
of the media that he passed on it he
took an issue with that phraseology what
do you say on that subject Tom Verducci
yeah well they were in it for call you
know there were tips depending on what
reports you want to believe they just
didn't have the package the Pirates
wanted you either Miguel Andujar or
Glaber Taurus or kind of the stumbling
points in that deal you know they tried
Verlander I don't think at the time I
remember he wasn't throwing that well
and I don't think the Yankees were as
high on him and listen he's become a
much much better pitcher with Houston
Astros than he was in Detroit I mean
he's good in Detroit but he's gone next
level but yeah wasn't there there mo
here to try to win the World Series with
a really deep deep bullpen and you look
at the starting pitcher in this starting
pitching in this world series it's
expensive you know the average salary
for these starters is 25 million dollars
and they're all they're all older you're
not gonna see anybody in their 20s tardy
a game the World Series here so it's
expensive to get great starting pitching
and it takes a while
the only homegrown one in this world
series is Stephen Strasburg so yeah you
do have to go out and get it the Cubs
did it certainly in 2016 with their
rotation but yeah I think the Yankees
have to look at maybe being a little
more diverse offensively watching these
Nationals put the ball in play and you
know watching the Red Sox last year that
certainly works this time of year right
fighting off two strike pitches Yankees
terrific home run team not as good as
putting the ball play and you know I
still look at in these games catching
defensively super important I mean go
back to the slider that Chapman threw
out seve it why is he throwing him a
slider right there you know just you
don't need to attack him with a fastball
but throw a hundred around the edge of
the zone so the call of that pitch the
problems that Sanchez had blocking balls
calling games and it bled into his
offense I thought it really took his
offensive game down because he is a
great offensive player you know that's
something looking at in a postseason
environment I know he's improved a lot
but I think that came back to haunt them
a little bit most season so I like what
Cashman said though rich it wasn't a
failed season was a failed game you know
they lost in the last at-bat in the ALCS
Game six so they're they're still darn
good and they'll be back again next year
a couple more questions for you Tom Tom
Verducci here on the Rich Eisen show
what's the post mortem for the Dodgers
here in Los Angeles I mean talk about a
disappointing campaign not even making
me the LCS what happens here in LA yeah
that one's got a heart I thought this
was their best chance going in with
Kershaw Ryu and Bueller I thought this
was a team that could let the starters
go a little deeper in the game and
offensively I thought they were varied
enough to win so the question is you
know Gerrit Cole out there and a lot of
people think he wants to pitch on the
west coast so the Dodgers do something
like that that has not been the way they
operate under Andrew Friedman right they
haven't been thrown out there and buying
up huge free agents they've extended
some of their own Jansen and Kershaw but
they haven't been a big player on the
big name guys but if Cole's out there I
think if you're the Dodgers or anybody
you have to see if he wants to play for
your team and what the number is yeah I
think he's going to wind up with the
Angels or somebody on the west coast but
at least what his teammates say so I
think they'd be involved in that but I
love the core of this team still rich I
mean this kid Gavin Luck the youngster
at second base can be a player Will
Smith was a rookie behind the plate
disappointing yeah I think this one hurt
more than the last few but again I'm
talking about a team that I think it's
going to be again odds-on favorite to
win their division next year and who's
the Mets target now that Girardi went to
Philadelphia and and and they still are
looking who's the guy I think it's Tim
Bogar and I actually think it's been
sent Bolger all along Girardi was kind
of the only one in the mix with really
extensive managing experience for the
Mets partly because I think you know he
knows the New York landscape obviously
want a championship there I think that's
important or semi important it's not the
number one priority when you're in New
York but I just make Brody Witt
bandwagon in his like his best buddy in
the world is AJ Hinch right and I think
that AJ is kind of the template for what
Brody would look for and that to me
means Tim Bogar really smart dude you
know he's done his time as a coach you
know he's managed if you want to count
interim in Texas for about a month or so
Wright has experience in New York has
connections to the team played for the
team and I think the fact that he's been
affiliated now with this national team
that done so well the last few years
really helps him so I would think it's
gonna wind up bogar all right I lied
one who is Jayce Tingler I mean who is
that it's honestly sounded like a Boogie
Nights character to me Tom
so who's Jace Tingler the new Padres
manager yeah he's a guy AJ Prowler who
knows really well from his time in Texas
Jason's a guy who has managed East Coast
he's been running player development
he's also gone to the Dominican and
managed he speaks Spanish well he just
is really close with AJ Pirela he picks
all the box that AJ would look for in a
manager and I think Ron Washington does
too and that's why it was interesting he
had a guy like wash a lot of experience
Jace who you couldn't pick out if you
bumped into him at the local supermarket
but I think we great to put watch on
that staff I don't know if they can get
him away from the Braves as a bench
coach he'd be terrific but AJ problem
knew both of us both those guys from
Texas and I think the fact that he's
just so close with Jason it's kind of
like his model of what a manager should
be without the experience you never know
first time guys but listen 10 postseason
teams this year rich eight of them had a
manager on his first job so my
experience has been devalued in baseball
when it comes to managing maybe this guy
is the next Alex Cora good but I think
we'll find out about Jace pretty dark
soon because they had some really good
young talent Tom enjoy the experience in
the atmosphere in Washington DC this
weekend and the baby shark attack and
all of that stuff enjoy it yeah thanks a
lot for it appreciate it you got it
thanks to the call that's Tom Verducci
one of the best in the business for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app